so my number five would be Assassin's
Creed syndicate I spent way too much
time in that game and the reason that I
rate it so highly is because of that I
finished the main story I really love
the character that really loves the new
traversal mechanics and the new
introduction of these twins I really
like the way even Jacob bounce off each
other but I kept going back to it game
even after I was to finish something
about all the collectibles and all the
different little narrative tidbits you
get from the side missions pulled me
back in so I kept going back for more
and I eventually one hundred percent
completed it so for that it is my number
five so my number four is Sybil it's a
small indie game made by Nina Freeman
she's working on tacoma and she made a
sort of shoe it is she made an
autobiographical game about meeting a
guy on the internet and falling in love
with him and then eventually meeting up
with him in real life to do it I was one
of those really awkward kids that grew
up or grew into her adolescents on the
internet in chat rooms and typing out
stupid things and connecting with these
people online because where I lived
there weren't a lot of people that are
really connected with that I really
identified with so I sort of learned how
to socialize on the internet and I
really identified with it and I think
the game is short but it does it in a
really it tells its message in a really
powerful way
top three number three rise of the Tomb
Raider I feel that that game has the
best level design of any game that came
out this year Lara aside I really like
what they're doing with her character
but I really felt like I was making
progress and and learning new things and
really developing her in a way that was
personal to me you could pick all the
different skills in three different
categories and you could make her a
survivor or make her you know a hunter
and i really liked customizing her and i
also think that the way that they
designed those levels the way that
there's you know like a shimmer of white
on a Ledge that you can climb up or a
tree that you can climb up and the way
that it gives you a lot in the
environment to either craft the bomb or
maybe going running and gunning i really
liked that freedom and i really think it
did a really good job world building so
for that it is in my top three
everything on the rapture is a sad
[ __ ] game it is so sad the soundtrack
the story the whole mystery behind what
the light is and what it does to people
and it struck me in a really powerful
way it's about you know losing people
and not necessarily losing them to death
but losing them to you know petty spats
and losing them to the way you grow
apart and you know life is really weird
and all that stuff and I think that that
game did a really good job of capturing
that sentiment in a sort of supernatural
really interesting story I still listen
to the soundtrack it's haunting I
sometimes I listen to it when I need to
cry it's a really really good game and
it's really short it's a nice little
contained package and it's definitely
something that if you haven't
experienced the game that gives you that
sort of gut punch you should probably do
it with everybody's gone to the rapture
so what's my favorite game of the year
alright so I don't give a [ __ ] about
borderlands the killers in the
borderlands did it for me it's a really
great story about the little guy you're
not chasing vault hunters you don't have
crazy powers you're just some guy and
some girl out there trying to survive
and trying to make their way in the
world it takes a lot of really
interesting themes from the borderlands
universe that sort of expounds on them
and then adds in some new stuff like the
meaning of friendship and what happens
when your heroes disappoint you the
script is hilarious I can't name any
other game this year that had me
literally had to stop and pause so I
could roll on the ground and laugh and
just absolutely explode and it's so good
and it's wrapped up in a way that like a
TV show would be wrapped up where you
have liked the episode and cliff hanger
and they do that really well with their
fingers additionally all those
borderland games begin with that really
big sort of musical intro sequence and
every episode has bet and in every
episode they just nail it the children's
of borderlands from Telltale Games is my
game of the year for 2015
you